new world is set to take us to the
mystical land of eternum on september
28th after a successful summer of play
tests now we've got a brand new look at
this mmorpg as it heads towards its open
beta on september 9th and if you're
watching on twitch make sure to connect
your account to get the twitch drop of
the verdant trapper apparel skin by
watching 15 minutes of this very show
and after the world premiere check out
my interview with game director scott
lane take a look
the stories you've heard
they don't tell the all truth
the island is indeed a place of legend
there is power
and fast riches as well
but many who've sought to claim them
have simply vanished
without a trace
your ship is stocked and your crew
assembled
charge your course and your fate
we can pretend
no longer
this corruption must be stopped
[Applause]
i will say a prayer for the souls of
your crew
that was the gamescom trailer for new
world and joining me now is the game
director from new world scott lane uh
scott how you doing
i'm great jeff how are you i'm great you
guys had a very successful closed beta
test this summer right tell us about it
yeah we were thrilled and humbled by how
that went you know over one million
people showed up to play and there were
two billion minutes watched on twitch
it was just so fun for the team to get
to play alongside everyone watch those
streamers and we got so much good
feedback the team's even more focused on
shipping a great game than they were
before
now the game is coming out uh september
28th but before then there will be a
public beta for fans yeah we're opening
it up to the public from september 9th
through the 12th so if you're not
familiar with new world come check it
out and if you want more information on
how to participate you can go to
www.newworld.com
before we go i want to ask you about uh
post launch content uh what do you have
uh planned for players after september
28th well we are completely committed to
making eternum a living breathing world
that players will come back to again and
again for years to come
so for us launch is really the beginning
it's day one
we're going to continue to add features
well beyond launch and we're going to
continue engaging with the players to
help drive our goals and where we take
the game
i can't get specific on what we're
talking about but i can't give you some
hints
players have already been asking for
more supernatural elements and more
weapons so we got a pretty cool way to
combine those into a deliverable that
they'll see shortly after launch
and then players have been asking for
more group content and expedition so
we're working toward that as well
and you know with the holidays right
around the corner i'm pretty excited to
see what that might look like on
attorney
all right thanks so much for joining us
scott
thanks jeff